we're now a little bit into the month of
November 2019 so it is time for another
monthly update video in which I'm going
to talk about what we've got coming up
in this month of November it's a little
bit more low-key and what went on in the
very very busy month of October I always
like to begin by highlighting three big
things so big thing number one as every
year we've done for a while we're gonna
be doing some polling to get some
suggestions for some of the authors that
I'll be talking about in the worlds of
speculative fiction series which is
going into its fifth year so stay tuned
for videos and blog posts about that if
you want to have a voice big thing
number two I'm actually taking the
November writing challenge but I'm
definitely not writing a novel instead
I'm gonna do what I saw somebody else do
starting today which is to post in my
blog or exes D&O ntk every single day
through the month of November I've got a
lot of updates I need to give in there
and some some other writings I want to
do so that's a good venue for me and
finally a big thing number three since
I've got a little bit more time on my
hands I'm going to be getting back to
taking the lecture videos and turning
them into Sadler's lectures podcasts and
putting those out there for for people
to listen to as they're doing their work
or entertainment or walking or whatever
it is that they do so those are the
three big things for this month and
let's talk now about what went on in
October October 2019 was an incredibly
busy month for me I'm currently teaching
seven classes for four different
institutions two of which are online the
other five of which have a signal
pick an online component to them so a
lot of development a lot of grading a
lot of meeting with students a lot of
office hours that keeps me busy as it is
but October was also the month in which
we had the big stoic calm and stoic on
exes and stoic week and so his editor of
Stoicism today I certainly had my hands
full doing all the gathering information
and promoting things so I'll talk about
the the stoicism related stuff here in
Milwaukee we and by we I mean the
Milwaukee stoic fellowship although most
of the organizing was done by myself and
my wife and partner Andy shaka we put on
a Stella connects event and that's kind
of a big deal we did it here in
Milwaukee we had 65 people attend and
the only reason we didn't have more is
because we picked a room that maximum
occupancy 70 because there were people
on the wait list for it as well and
despite a fire alarm going off it went
quite well we had three excellent
speakers at the beginning of the day we
did lightning round talks then Andy and
I finished up the event with a workshop
on stoicism and relationships I also
participated remotely in stoic on axe
Brisbane Brisbane is in Australia
literally on the other side of the world
from here so what I did is I created a
lecture video for them and then you know
did some QA by by Skype and that's often
how it has to be done in these remote
locations and you can see the videos for
all of these linked to below if you just
click on the see more in the video
description part you can see all the
still account X videos and you can see
the stoical NX Brisbane video as well I
also began the month with a unusual sort
of event for me which was a talk not
about science fiction authors but a talk
with a science fiction author
and that was Veronica Roth who you may
know from the divergent series but she's
written some other things as well she's
got a new book of short stories out so
her publicist contacted me and said
Veronica would like to have a
conversation with you at Boswell
bookstore one of our independent
bookstores here in the Milwaukee area
and so I agreed went in and we had a
really lovely conversation and did some
Q&A afterwards I got some books signed
for both myself and my kids who are fans
of her her fiction we also did the
worlds of speculative fiction monthly
events and this time we focused on
adults Huxley we talked about brave new
world but also brave new world revisited
the island ape in essence so we were
looking at utopia and dystopia and I did
my usual online events as well they're
pared back a little bit this month so I
just did my AMA that has asked me
anything my half-hour Hagel Q&A and
discussion sessions and philosophy chat
we didn't get to any video premiere
unfortunately because I ran out of time
and we also didn't do the philosophy
pop-ups but I'm planning on bringing
those back this coming month I did do
some interviews I was on the River West
radio another morning show talking about
stoicism and stoic on acts and the big
stoic on conference and I'll probably be
going back on there sometime in the
future I also had the episode that was
recorded with the post-structuralist
tent revival a bunch of young scholars
out mostly I think at duquesne and we
talked about ancient philosophy and
theology and takes on Lumos and anger so
that was a lot of fun as I mentioned I'm
teaching a lot of classes right now
academically believe it or not I'm
teaching seven because I had all these
requests for teaching I turned down an
additional six so it's one of those when
it rains it pours kinds of things I also
you know
my child Maddy visit here and we'd spent
some time over fall break just kind of
taking it easy did a lot of tutoring and
a lot of philosophical counseling have
quite a few new clients I'm not exactly
sure how they're finding me since I
haven't improved my web presence at all
the way that all the guides tell you
you're supposed to do but somehow things
are sticking I put out some some videos
this month but not quite as much as I
would have liked
mostly core concept videos augustin and
then decart these are videos that I shot
from my classes this semester and early
release to my students and patreon
supporters and then release to the
general public and of course there's
quite a few event videos of these
various talks the stoic on X talks the
annals Huxley talked as well and I think
that's that's pretty much it for that
month so what's coming up in November
it's somewhat of a more low-key month I
actually looked at the calendar and I
don't have any public or online events
other than the stoic fellowship going
all the way from the second week or from
the end of the second week of November
on which is good because I'm gonna use
the Thanksgiving break to sort of have a
little mini vacation here not going
anywhere but I'm gonna just chill out
and do minimal work over that time so
what do we get already did the AMA for
the month yesterday I'll put a link to
that I'm deciding you know that I'm
gonna have a more regular schedule for
these events ama's will always be on the
first Saturday of every month twelve
o'clock noon so you can put it on your
calendar and have a good idea and you
can always go to the reason io calendar
and find out when events are going to be
or my Facebook page on the sixth which
is coming up this week that's a
Wednesday at 6 p.m. at the Shorewood
learn at the Shorewood Public Library
but rather the Frank Weinberg library
and Mequon I'm continuing on with
finishing the third year is at the third
of the fourth year fourth year the
philosophers in the midst of history
quarterly series and this time I'll be
talking about a favorite of mine Simone
de Beauvoir somebody who I teach in my
classes quite frequently of course she's
associated very closely with jean-paul
Sartre but she was doing quite a lot of
work on her own as well and her life is
quite interesting so we'll be talking
about her on the 13th at 5:00 p.m. this
is an online event we'll have our
monthly public Haegele Q&A session so
you can log in and do video conferencing
with me and we'll talk about things
Hegel related on the 14th at the
Brookfield Public Library at 7 p.m. we
continue on with our worlds of
speculative fiction series which is
getting to the end of its fourth year as
well and we're gonna be talking about
Bram Stoker so of course we're talking
about Dracula but also the stories in
Dracula's guests guests rather and layer
the white worm Lady of the shroud and
perhaps some other stories as well so
that should be quite fun had really been
enjoying rereading Dracula and layer the
white worm to get ready for that
Saturday the 16th at 12 p.m. we will
have another video premiere in that
video will be another one of the
self-directed study videos Sadler's
advice this time it will be on studying
early Christian philosophy so that will
include you know it won't be about
Augustine but it will go up to about
Augustine's time who we would read what
you would check out how to approach
these texts there's actually a lot of
cool stuff there also on the 16th at 3
p.m. we will be having our philosophy
chat session for patreon supporters and
that brings me up to about you know the
end of the month where you can look at
again on the calendar and you'll see the
Milwaukee stoic fellowship Shorewood
public
library if you're interested in that you
can find the meetup group or find it
linked to here now we had a couple
things that I mentioned in the three big
things to talk about so I'm going to be
putting out a call for suggestions for
these our first round suggestions for
the authors we ought to do in the worlds
of speculative fiction series this
coming year year 5 I've already got
about seven or eight people picked out
some of whom are holdovers from last
year that we didn't get to because I was
ill like Mary Shelley some of whom are
people who have recently come across
like China Melville and others you know
as well that I've been wanting to get to
for some time but there's room for four
or five additional ones and so if you
want to participate you can get in on
that and then we'll have a final vote
later on once we get it narrowed down a
bit what else the the month of November
there's a writing challenge that's
carried out and I'm not sure if it's
national or international
I'm never participating in it it's a you
know writing a novel now I don't have
the the chops or the time for writing a
whole novel during the month in November
I'm a busy guy but I can do what I
noticed somebody else pledging to do
during this month which is to start
writing more frequently in my blog or
xst anoetic a my author blog that I've
had since I think about 2009 or 2010 so
it's time for me to start using that
more frequently for updates and musings
and things like that as I pledged to
earlier before I got so busy the the
other thing that I'm going to be doing
is more podcast work so look for
aristotle podcast episodes on the
metaphysics to continue then i'm going
to have some radio maria rilke as
letters to a young poet i know some of
you have been hoping for those
and then some on an Psalms prose loggia
a text that I've been reading and
rereading boy since graduate school what
else do we have going on November I've
got a lot of preliminary work to do for
redesigning some of the classes that
I'll be teaching next semester I have my
class assignments in I have four classes
already lined up business ethics down at
Carthage College two classes for
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
one of which is my intro to humanities
class which I want to redesign to make
it a little bit easier for the students
to navigate and stay on track with and
then I'm also teaching I'm developing
and ethics for artists and designers
class and redeveloping it essentially
but putting it into an online setting
for them at my ad and then I'm doing
another class in the second chance Pell
which is a prison program here in
Wisconsin spearheaded by Milwaukee Area
Technical College I'm going to be
teaching ethics for them remotely and so
that takes a lot of design I'm gonna
have to shoot a lot of videos for that
in order to help keep them on track and
you know give them what they need and
redesign some of the assignments and
activities as well one of the big
challenges of that class is that it's
really not a class all the prisoners
have to not be afforded opportunities to
communicate with each other so we can't
do something like a class right
everything has to be set up so
individual students can work out on
their own so there's all of that work to
be doing I've also got some editing work
to do for Stoicism today and we're gonna
get cracking finally on something that
I've wanted to do for a long time which
is to begin work on a new volume of
selected essays from stoicism today so
we're gonna get the groundwork laid for
that and you know continue on with my
clients and consulting philosophical
counseling tutorials we're sort of
bringing things to a close and the
classes I still have a good bit of class
development work to do in some of my
classes and a lot of video that I have
to shoot this month so I'm planning on
finishing I'm going to be releasing the
core concept videos on decart I shot all
of them this last month but I do haven't
released all of them I'm also doing the
same with some David Hume videos some
new ones on the inquiry concerning human
understanding and I'm shooting some more
material on David Hume hopefully tonight
again early early release that to my
patreon supporters and to my students
and then the general public gets a seat
a bit later on this month I'm also
shooting video stuff on William James
specifically on chapter two of
pragmatism and on the will to believe on
AJ Ayers language truth and logic
primarily just chapters 1 & 6 and Vidkun
Stein's philosophical investigations
mostly just the stuff about language
games but we'll see we'll see how far I
get into that I'm pledging to get back
to shooting half our Haegele videos last
month you know I had sort of plotted
some time but then I got ill at a couple
points and wasn't able to do it
got that self directed study video to do
and I'm going to get some book reviews
done this month so that is what the
month ahead holds hopefully you can meet
me at some of these face-to-face events
or in some of the online events and make
sure of course to give your feedback if
you've got a stake in the worlds of
speculative fiction series and yeah
that's pretty much it the last thing
I'll say we're already lining up
speaking engagements for the coming year
so if you're interested in bringing me
in to talk about something or do a
workshop now is a good time to get on
the calendar while there's there's
plenty of openings before things start
to fill up so if
that's something that interests you you
can write me of course at Gregg at
reason io comm that's the best way to
get in touch with me by email and we'll
take it from there so hope all of you
have a great month ahead and I'll see
some of you face to face or online
you